hey ruby hi how you doing i'm good
i love this movie so much you're so
awesome in it
um you posted all these photos to
instagram where the cast is like bloody
and beaten up looking
how intense was shooting on this film it
was pretty intense
it was pretty intense yeah uh especially
the stuff that sam and i did together we
were outdoors you know people are like
oh is that fake snow
is that a set no no we're we're
literally in the snow in
a very remote part of hungary but it was
beautiful and we did it over a couple of
days because we didn't have a lot of
light
physically downhills we're climbing up
trees we're flipping over each other and
uh but it was high adrenaline and we
needed to stay warm so what kind of
starch that we got to be so physical in
the elements
it was a lot of fun that's amazing he
said specifically on that final scene
that you guys worked really hard
together like you
really wanted to make that look as
realistic as possible yeah we
we really did yeah um it was really fun
too just the whole film watching you
and sam go toe to toe um what's it like
working with him as an actor
it's so much fun he's such a delight
it's it's when i told people that i was
working with him
you know at first i and i was very
excited about working with tom wilkinson
and andy circus people that i've watched
and
grown up admiring i told my mom you know
everyone's so excited about them and
then everyone else
was just like with sam hewitt but sam
hewitt tell us about is he dating anyone
what does he smell like what's his hair
like what color
i'm like guys come on he's a human being
you can't
you know can you get his number no i
can't get his number for you what are
you doing
uh i didn't realize that before i met
him what
a huge sex symbol he is and how much
women just love
him women men everyone loved him and
then i met
him i was like yeah this experience this
tracks
he's a perfect specimen of a human he's
an amazing actor
he's so kind and he's funny he's great i
mean i you know i should date him but
he's just great
yeah the the loyalty surrounding
outlander the fan base
is next level i did say could he get you
a cameo on that show just because i love
that show so much
you would be awesome he thought it was
too cold and you wouldn't appreciate it
did he really yeah
i i mean i do it i do i do anything
actually that sam asked me to do he's
just
i i have such a good time working with
him oh i love that so much so i want to
ask like every role that you're in
you're so much fun to watch what's it
like always being a cool badass in
movies
i mean it's great it's always great to
know that
i'm someone that's in that kind of
handful of people that everyone okay
there's an action role or there's a
badass or there's a villain like
and there's a smaller amount of women
that they've allowed to do these roles
than
men the list of men is so long and it's
even if a guy's never done action they
they'll still
choose a guy you know whereas with women
they wanted to be true and tried and
have they done action and is it
believable
and so you know i've done a lot of these
and and a lot of them i haven't and when
i don't
decide to do something because maybe
it's too similar to a character i've
already played or
whatever it is i'm always so excited to
be like but i can't wait to see who they
they can't wait to see who they put in
this position
because maybe we'll get another female
that gets that opportunity to be part of
this kind of
action world and it is growing it's ever
growing but i think it needs to grow
faster but you know in this case i was
into the action but i also really liked
the psychology behind it is what made it
so important to what i've done before
yeah completely and really quickly i
wanted to ask if you watched the new
season of batwoman yet and what do you
think of javicia leslie taking on the
role
division is amazing i've only watched
like one or two episodes i just wanted
to see you know
everyone cry over cocaine and see what
was happening and see what happened to
the suit
um and i wanted to see the car the
batmobile but she's doing a fantastic
job everyone i mean everyone already was
doing a great job so it's good to see
that it's doing really well
amazing what a pleasure getting to talk
to you congratulations on the film
thank you very much cheers appreciate it
you